well [ __ ] Assassin's Creed so Assassin's
Creed is yet more proof that video games
don't translate well to movies in this
one you have Michael Fassbender Michael
Fassbender gets lethal injection and
killed because of the kill the guy this
organization called Abstergo gets his
body into like hey you're not actually
dead and they hook him up to this
machine called the Animus basically
through genetic memory in the Animus a
person can relive the memories of their
dead ancestors and they do that because
there's this item they need to find only
his ancestor would have known where it
was this item will help them cure
mankind of anger hostility aggression
knowledge it and from there the movie
sequential he starts to put you to sleep
I'm serious mad how hard is this essence
it's a cool premise stick with it and
keep us in the past for God's sakes
there's a good movie in this movie it's
called everything when they're in 1400
xx as long as you're there it's
entertaining enough but he only actually
goes into this animus machine and lives
those memories three times in the movie
and I felt like every time he did it was
a very short video game demo and after
that he gets pulled out and now we're
hanging out at Abstergo not really that
interesting at all and granted that is
how the game is he goes into a memory
you play this essence creed he comes out
of the memory however that premise of
being in the past and then in the
present day think that works when you
have about 15 hours of gameplay to do it
with when you have a two hour movie
doesn't work that well put him in the
machine keep him in the machine you can
have dialog of people monitoring him so
you can get there his schemes going but
just a dude put him there and keep him
in the past that's where the interesting
shit's happening I mean really is there
an assassin's Creed game that has
Desmond Miles on the cover because
everything happening in present day is
so interesting no people want to see the
SS and [ __ ] show them the assassin [ __ ]
but even then when the action was going
down and he was an assassin it's not
like you know they just hook him into
the matrix and he's just laying in a
chair or anything like that he's in this
machine where he in present day is
miming the memories as they're happening
so whenever an action scene would go
down actions happening through cut the
present-day he's in the animus and it
shows him miming and fighting nothing
then it goes back to the action it was
really jarring you couldn't connect with
the action and the past because it kept
snapping
present-day and in the past again it's
kind of like imagine a 3d movie where it
goes from 3d then to 2d then to three D
then D to D is really jarring for your
eyes you just have to adjust like that
it's just a matter of time where you
just have to adjust it okay now we're
back of the action all right now we're
not nor back like jarring [ __ ] like
people weren't good and Michael
Fassbender is good in the movie Jeremy
Irons was Jeremy Irons everyone who
tries they do well because they are
their baseline characters you be Jeremy
Irons you be Michael Fassbender you be
Marion Cotillard what else did just do
you there we go there are a couple of
moments where this movie looks like it's
gonna crawl itself out of the mud and
was even entertaining for me but all of
it happened in the past and his movie
sets up for a sequel that we will never
see in a movie that people probably
shouldn't watch the bummer is all the
early reports this movie might be good
was because it stuck to the source
material and it does really it's an
interesting premise and when you look at
it at its baseline it actually does have
accurate Assassin's Creed lorina it had
content that was interesting that was
established in the games already so
really I give the games credit for
setting up really interesting lore that
this movie took and didn't do anything
interesting with couple of action
sequences were fun enough that all took
place in the assassin timeline
everything present-day was boring as
[ __ ] and sloppily done I will say
Assassin's Creed you're not gonna
remember this in t-minus one day yeah I
already forgot why do I look forward to
them rebooting Mortal Kombat that
shouldn't anyhow so Assassin's Creed
have you seen it what did you think
about it have you played it what did you
think of those games with every thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you
[Music]